I told you last week about Secretary of
Health and Human Services Tom price his
use of private jets instead of
commercial flights and government
airplanes and the pressure just built
and built over the weekend and prices
now out prices private travel and use of
military jets for these overseas trips
has cost taxpayers more than a million
extra dollars we have a quote from the
White House about the resignation where
they said Secretary of Health and Human
Services Thomas price offered his
resignation earlier today and the
president accepted it Trump had
previously said he would decide by
Friday night whether he was going to
fire price so this is basically it's a
forced resignation right this guy's use
of private planes is particularly I mean
I say it all the time in the Trump era
it's hypocritical because price was one
of these major vocal critics of wasteful
spending by the government he put 20 he
took 26 flights on charter planes since
May according to a Politico
investigation and in his resignation
letter to Donald Trump Tom Price said
that he was resigning so that the
administration can quote move forward
without further disruption somehow I
don't believe that the resignation of
Tom price is going to stop the
disruptions that are constantly going on
within the Trump administration but for
me the big story isn't really prices
resignation specifically I mean yeah
he's a total scumbag claiming to be for
the people and wanting to put in place
replacements for Obamacare that would be
terrible for the people while spending
their tax dollars on playa a private
plane and chartered plane travel I won't
be shedding any tears over Tom Price
having lost his job but Tom Price never
should have been Secretary of HHS to
begin with never in a million years
and in fact Tom Price resigning after a
career of saying he's all about watching
out for the people this is the first
time he's actually made a move that will
reduce government waste he's left
government himself that's the one thing
we can point to that Tom Price has done
that actually reduces government waste
and let's add to that because it's
bigger than Tom Price if
few private jet flights are enough to
get somebody to resign why are there no
repercussions for the endless millions
of dollars that Trump is funneling into
his own family businesses and the real
story is let's look at the growing list
of major Trump resignations and endless
minor Trump resignations and sometimes
they are sort of forced resignations or
firings this is a list only of I guess
the somewhat notable ones and there's a
whole other list Preet Bharara the US
attorney for the Southern District of
New York might have been getting a
little too close to Donald Trump's
businesses he was fired by Donald Trump
Stephen Bannen this top White House
propagandist not his formal title of
course but that's what I call the guy he
was probably forced to resign by new
chief of staff John Kelly James Comey
FBI director fired by Donald Trump Mike
dubbed key director of White House
communications now you might say wait a
second it was scary Moochie scaramouche
II was fired yeah scaramouche II was in
that role after dub he himself was in
the role and had resigned Boris Epstein
a Trump aide also a propagandist Michael
Flynn disgraced national security
adviser forced to resign is Sebastian
Gorka the white nationalist connected
deputy assistant to Trump Trump's
personal attorney mark Cassavetes
stepped away we know about Paul Manafort
the former campaign manager and chairman
Tom Price the Secretary of Health and
Human Services as I mentioned Reince
Priebus former chief of staff chuck
rosenberg this is a new one acting head
of the DEA he's out he can't deal with
the Trump stuff
scaramouche II as you probably know of
director of white house comms
Keith Schiller Trump's longtime
bodyguard was either sort of pushed or
decided to step away Sean Spicer a
notable one White House press secretary
and Sally Yates fired Deputy Attorney
General briefly the blanket reaction is
what couldn't have happened to nicer
people but it's been 8.5 months many
more or less notable and I'm sure I
missed a bunch of these firings are also
on the list half the country thinks
there's nothing to see here right half
the country believes this is normal it's
a patriotic run-of-the-mill Republican
administration and the signal that we've
now identified if Trump
says publicly that he has some ones he
has full confidence in someone that
should be a red flag to you that that
person could be gone soon and aye aye
sir you know we joke a lot about Trump
being riddled by scandals and firings
and resignations it's good because it
prevents Trump from being able to carry
out his agenda like it's hard to get the
wall built when it's constant scandals
and investigations and that's true but
this is also an administration that
can't even get it together to in a
timely manner help our fellow US
citizens in Puerto Rico so in a sense
it's good that the Trump administration
is constantly distracted by firings and
resignations and scandals and
investigations but it also has real
impact which is that this is a totally
impotent White House now who might be
next even minuchin is a possibility he's
been involved in some of the same
taxpayer dollars for personal travel
stuff as Tom Price Jared Kushner the
heat is mounting on Jared Kushner so
those are at the top of my list but this
is actually having a real impact on
people and that's why it's not all fun
and games that Trump's administration is
scandal-ridden a send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show today's
program is made possible in part by
movement watches movement watches was
started by a couple broke college kids
who would go to department stores they'd
see watch as they liked and they'd be
four or five hundred dollars so they
said well we need a cool stylish watch
but for a lot less money so what they do
is sell exclusively online and have
actually sold over a million watches to
over 160 countries they cut out the
middleman and have really stylish
watches that start at just 95 dollars I
wear my movement watch all the time I'm
wearing it today
people love it they see it they say
that's a really cool-looking watch where
did you get that and I tell them and I
also tell them they can get 15% off if
they want you can go to MVM t-dot-com
slash Pakman and get 15% off today with
free shipping and free returns these
make really great gifts I've actually
given a couple of watches as gifts and
people love it mostly because it looks
like a way more expensive watch than it
is again they start at $95 and you can
save 15% MVM t-dot-com /p AKM